ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the 45th and final
President of the United States.
(applause and cheering)
-(reporters clamoring)
-(camera shutters clicking)
Mr. President, Mr. President.
-Quick question, Mr. President.
-Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, everyone calm down
and don't panic.
As you know, only a few hours
ago I was in Paris
with President
Emmanuel Lewis Macaroni,
and his beautifully fit,
tight wife.
That's the kind of hottie you
find in Paris, not Pittsburgh,
let me tell you.
But the events of
the past few days
have forced me to return home
to update you
on the status
of this terrible outbreak.
What outbreak?
The horrible virus that has
infected the brains
of millions of people, forcing
them them to believe bogus,
ridiculous,
well-documented things
about me and Russia.
Some know it as Kremlin-fluenza.
To others it's Mos-cow disease,
and to an unlucky few,
it's Spy-arrhea.
Uh, those aren't diseases.
Yes, they are.
I'm wearing the science coat.
It's spread through
fake news media
and I alone can fix it.
Now, don't worry, we're gonna
contain this outbreak,
because tonight's theme
is containment.
I want to ask you
about your son.
My son, Eric?
Thank you so much for asking.
He's doing so great.
Clear eyes, soft gums,
can't lose.
No, no, your other son.
-Jared, of course.
-Donald, Jr.
Well, in a way,
Jared is the junior
I never Donalded.
Those emails prove
that your son met
with a surrogate of the
Russian government.
No parent wants to talk about
their first born.
Your first born is like
the first pancake.
It's misshapen,
it's a disappointment,
and you wish you hadn't named it
after yourself.
You name your pancakes?
Keep my pancakes
out of your mouth.
Now, everyone,
barricade your doors,
convert all your assets to gold,
and throw your loved ones
under the bus.
I'm the president,
collude believe it?
Let's roll.